at the end of the day if you really
wanted to be wealthy say
how did i do today did i make the right
choices was i ethical was i purpose
driven was i was i was am i interested
in making a difference was i fair was i
tempered
did i really think before i spoke what
what did i remember reading about that
book about that person that did it how'd
i do
and if you said i when did i fall from
grace when did i lose it okay
i want that opportunity again
i want another shot at that and i'm
going in this way what would love do in
this situation what would greatness do
and now you you evolve your experience
and somehow there's a door there's an
opening something shifts something's
changing and now here we go we climb
another ladder and then all of a sudden
there's another challenge and then
people who finally arrive at their
abundance they could care less if
they're abundant they're already knowing
that they've earned the right for it so
so there's sometimes a shortcut in the
process uh if we're if we really learn
we really get it
but the trial and error is so
important because
not only is the person earning the right
to be wealthy
but they're earning the right to live in
worthiness worthy to receive like hey
you people people come to our work all
the time for a lot of reasons and one of
the common reasons is they want to get
healthy yeah and in their own because
they're dealing with a very serious
health condition and i always say the
same thing to him
stop wanting to be healthy learn the
formula yeah on how to get healthy learn
the formula on how to heal and the
healing will be the side effect of it if
you're obsessing about why am i not
healed you're still the old person
you could become that person every day
right
turns out that when you sit down
and the people that we interview that
have had significant changes
when it's no longer about their health
but they are they are out of the
bleachers and they're on the playing
field and they are coming up against the
belief like one lady said god i i always
thought that
this work really worked this these
concepts are the truth but i never
believed it worked for me
and i was in a car accident in a
wheelchair and then she made the
decision that she was going to overcome
that belief now it was no longer about
her healing it was about overcoming the
belief but she overcame the belief and
showed up every day for herself when you
believe in yourself you believe in
possibilities when you believe in
possibilities you got to believe in
yourself you don't show up for yourself
you don't believe in it yeah and that's
why people don't do the work i mean if
you you believe that your thoughts
created reality
you would show up every day and create
and so a lot of people believe in their
past more than they believe in their
future a lot of people fall in love or
more in love with their past or romance
their past instead of romance their
future or love their future it's it's
that simple so
the initiation process of life
is always going to be there you're
always going to be challenged if if you
want to be a master well then you better
learn how to heal someone else and
you're going to fail a lot of times and
if you think that you're a failure then
you'll quit but if you feel like you
just didn't quite ding it yet and you
show up again
to just ding it and you keep evolving
your experience and go deeper how much
more can i open my heart how much more
can i surrender into this infinite field
how much more can i become can i walk is
it with my eyes open people
do meditations and they have great
meditations me included
and then you get up you open your eyes
and you're back in the program and
people want to know why they haven't
healed them we have testimonies of
people
they're speaking the truth they said
my ms
my rheumatoid and my lupus never went
away
i had great meditations i felt better
then i realized with my eyes open i was
still that person
and now next level they're in the game
catching themselves or catching how they
speak or watching how they think they're
not letting their body fall in the same
emotional state to put them in the same
past experience that the body's
believing in now this is the this is the
great part and when the person finally
breaks through from the chains
and there's a different consciousness of
freedom that happens
they look back at their past
they want to change one thing in their
past because it brought them to that
present moment that's the path no longer
existing that's the freedom so is it
worth the effort yeah it's no longer
about healing it's no longer about
abundance it's about who you're becoming
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and let's learn
how we can control our mind
enjoy
rule number two broadcast positivity
with bruce lipton in our mind we start
to realize that we're concerned we're
afraid we don't have enough i'm not safe
i'm not secure
and i say oh these thoughts i was
talking about the thoughts in your mind
go in and control your biology your
genetics your physiology and your health
and i go yes this is really true
i say well how can i tell you what your
thoughts are in a sense that can i read
your thoughts and i say yes you know i
could put wires on your head and it's
called electroencephalograph
and i could read your brain activity and
i go oh great i can see this brain
activity
i want to tell you something that's
profoundly important
we were programmed to believe that our
thoughts are contained in our head
that if i have a thought it's just for
me not for anybody else it's inside and
it's working through me
and now i want to tell you about a new
technology it's not electro
encephalograph it's called magneto
encephalograph
i say what's unique about that i say
read your brain i say yeah but so does
eeg i say yeah but eeg you put the wires
on the head and you get the electrical
activity conducted through the skin from
the brain and that's what i'm reading
and i said what's different about mg
the probe
is out here
and i said what does that mean
your thoughts are not contained in your
head
your thoughts are broadcast to the field
just like a radio broadcast
i say well what if i as an individual
have a thought that says
let's have peace in the world
and i broadcast out there in the street
and i say let's have peace and i look
around it's like
where's the peace i don't see the peace
and here's what the relevance is
each of us is broadcasting
if you get enough people
to have the same thought
that broadcast is amplified
each of us has a small power
but if you put a thousand people the
same thought ten thousand a hundred
thousand people with the same thought
you are broadcasting a most powerful
thought not just in your body but out in
the field i say your energy's in the
field the thought is in the field and
you go what does that mean and then i'll
give you this most wonderful quote
i used it the other day in a lecture
from albert einstein
and the quote is so important here's the
quote
the field
so a definite definition the field is
the invisible energy right now you're in
a field there's cell phone broadcast
television television radio broadcast
all kinds of information coming across
but guess what each one of you is a
broadcast in that field
the quote
the field
is the sole
governing agency of the particle
particle is the material realm
so what was einstein saying it's the
energy in the field that shapes the
physical experience of our lives
and if enough of us collectively have an
energy that's coherent and strong and we
broadcast a belief
we change the world
i just want you to recognize as much as
i wanted peace in the world if not
enough people are out there saying let's
have peace in the world there is no
peace
if i want to say let's have a war how
can you have a war you have to have
enough people convinced
that the war is going to benefit them so
that their broadcast say yes let's have
a war because i and my colleagues we're
all going to have a better result from
that
and the reality is this
the only things that change on this
planet collectively are when we
collectively share
thoughts
and yoga
when you're in your postures when you're
in your process your mind is sharing a
thought not just in your head
but all around you
so the whole idea about this is we have
to recognize
we are collectively creating reality
with our thoughts
and if we want to change reality it can
change instantly
the moment we become coherent the moment
we collectively are on the same platform
of thinking
you get enough people to say peace there
will be peace instantly in this world
but we've been programmed by other
people to
give them the power to tell us what we
need
and assad fiji has been telling us so
importantly what we need is not what
they tell us what we need is what we
know
and i really hope that you understand
this because when you have your thoughts
recognized it's not contained in your
head your thoughts out in the field
and that thought the field is the sole
governing agency of matter
and therefore
what this world is looking for at this
moment is an evolution
it's not an evolution of our biology our
biology has already evolved
it's an evolution of our consciousness
when we collectively as a population say
enough is enough it will end rule number
three pay attention with louise hay some
of you know my little blue book and the
fact that i've been doing a lot of work
with dis ease for a long time
and for every part of the body there is
a mental pattern and for every dis ease
in the body there is a mental pattern
and when you know what they are you can
begin to change the mental patterns
so that
you can change the dis-ease you see we
don't want to be sick no that's a
blanket statement sometimes people do
want to be sick because it's a good way
to get out of something
the rest of us know how to say no
if you don't know how to say no you may
have to create an illness in order to
say no
because that's we've made in society
we've made that a legitimate way of of
getting out of things
but basically we do not want to be ill
and yet we need every dis ease that we
have
because it is the body's way of telling
us
that there is a false idea in
consciousness
something that we're doing something
that we're believing something that
we're saying is not
for our highest good and the body is
saying please
it's sort of almost like tugging
saying pay attention
[Music]
so
[Music]
when we know what these patterns are it
gives us again a choice of whether we
wish to do something about it or not
rule number four keep learning with ian
mcgillcrest the word belief its root is
love
it is it's cognate with believe in in
german uh in
shakespeare in english the word leaf
meant my dear my dear one my dear lord
my dear whatever was the ones leaf lord
once leaf
husband wife whatever it was friend so
it's about and even the word glauben in
german which is the word for to believe
is related to
love leben so
initially
belief is not about believing six
impossible things before breakfast it's
about a disposition of your mind towards
the world and that's why i think it's so
important because we started from
attention and indeed one of the primal
things about
all the religious traditions and all the
good practices about paying attention to
the world stilling your own
monkey mind as they they call it you
know your own little chatter about it
and opening yourself to the possibility
of learning something and becoming just
a little bit wiser now if we don't do
that we're lost
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five think in
processes with andrew huberman a hashtag
growth mindset is one of the most
popular hashtags in social media but
most people don't actually know what it
means and again this is carol dweck's
discovery not mine it was discovered in
a group of kids that were doing math
problems or other kinds of puzzles that
they knew they couldn't get right but
they enjoyed doing them and they perform
exceedingly well on lots of sorts of
tests of that sort
when there is the right answer of course
and so what they do is they somehow
they're wired for effort they're wired
for the puzzle not for the solution and
when i say puzzle i don't mean the noun
puzzle i mean the verb for being puzzled
it for them feels good and so we need to
think
if we're talking about the nervous
system and we want to make it actionable
for high performance whether or not it's
in business or sport or otherwise we
want to think in terms of processes not
events
and verbs not nouns so growth mindset as
a verb as an action item you know
reward as a verb not just as oh you're
going to just pat yourself on the back
like it's no it's what you internalize
it's a process that's how the neural
circuits that underlie reward get
stronger and the beauty of of the brain
is that you have this thing of neural
plasticity which is its ability to
change itself throughout the whole
lifespan and the more you practice
this the better you get at it and it
does not mean you're walking around
talking delusionally about how great
life is when everything is terrible it
means you might even be very stoic you
might be
hopefully you're very rational but you
have the energy to continue to push
forward rule number six prime your brain
with john asrath every morning when you
wake up you have let's say let's say
it's ten attention units if you're using
two or three or four or five or six of
them on why you can't
your ability to stay focused
and
your ability to stay focused um is
happening at the conscious and
non-conscious level so if you're
processing stuff in the back of your
mind of something you're angry at
something you're mad at something that's
stressing out that or you don't have
enough money or you don't have the right
relationships or the context whatever if
you're stressing out about that stuff
and that's eating up your attention
units that's like having your computer
okay using up most of its energy in
what's behind that you're not using
and we all have a certain amount of
attention units every day
and so one of the things that you asked
me before that i can come back down the
rituals
is is using the attention units in a way
that is highly highly productive
versus yeah wasting a lot of time
and so my ritual we started earlier i
just remembered that
is you know wake up meditation
exercise uh
plant-based protein smoothie followed by
reviewing my goals mm-hmm every day you
remember every every day five minutes
the goals for the day the month every
year everything i review my overarching
goals i can do that fairly quickly
because that's my longer range goals i
can review the emotions that i want
because i'm committed to having those
emotions every day and feeling a certain
way every day and then i take a look at
from you know you know five years out
three years one year
90 days 60 days to today wow and so i
just review it and whatever piece of
paper laminated and on my computer
really yeah and i have it in a in a
booklet also
so when i travel it's really easy do you
have it with you no no it's it's a it's
a pretty big gotcha yeah it's like a
little manual you have to send me a
photo yeah yeah i'll send you it's
called my exceptional life blueprint i
like it and um and so the question many
people may ask is why
why would you do that well because
you're having 35 to 50 000 thoughts a
day right and your brain isn't certain
like what's really important what's not
but if you instruct your brain that
something is really important whether
it's something you don't want or
something you do it will actually pay
attention to you right so by priming my
brain early every day here is what i
want you to focus on here are the
emotions i want you to express through
me here's the behaviors that i need to
take
then i am on a daily basis
setting the course for what i want my
brain to focus on i am cognitively
priming the pump
and if i do it one day that's great if i
do it 60 days a hundred days my brain
goes hey i'm just going to make this
freaking automatic because i want to
conserve energy right right i'm just
going to make it automatic so not only
will you focus on it consciously i'm
just going to make everything happen
behind the scenes to help help you see
think and feel things that are congruent
with what you're training your life for
and what you want to achieve so i'm just
using the system better rule number
seven untie your mental blocks with guru
gopaldas a farmer
had three donkeys and was taking them
for sale to the market
on the way he saw a river and desired to
take a dip
there was an issue though
he only had two ropes
and thus would be able to tie only two
of his three donkeys to a tree
how to tie the third one he wondered
around there he saw a wise man
and approached him for a rope to tie his
third donkey
the man did not have a rope
but had a brilliant suggestion
he told the farmer
tie the two donkeys up to a tree with
the ropes you have
and make sure
that the third donkey is watching
then simply
pretend
to tie the third one
the farmer followed the man's advice
and went for a death
in the river
when he came back
he saw that the donkeys stood exactly at
the same spot where he had left them
he thanked the wise man untied the
donkeys
and patted the third one so it starts
moving as well
after going a little distance
he turned around
and was surprised to see the third
donkey
still standing at the very same
spot
he tried cajoling and talking to the
donkey
it did not help
he tried to push the donkey from behind
but it refused to move
from the spot
helpless
the farmer came back to the man who
asked him
did you untie the third donkey
untie
but i never tied him up replied the
farmer
the man said
you know that
the donkey
doesn't
it still thinks
it is tied up
the farmer
then went through the imaginary motions
of untying the donkey and guess what
sure enough
the donkey moved immediately as though
released
and walked over to join its two friends
what's holding us back
from moving ahead and reaching our
dreams
is it a lack of resources
is it a lack of opportunities
is it a lack of support
or
are we tied up by the imaginary ropes of
doubt
fear
hesitation
yes
we certainly need to work on the
external parameters
needed for our success
what is even more important
is that we untie
our mental blocks
and expedite our journey
towards
our goal rule number eight reflect with
nick kumahavong take the time each day
to check your intention
and what you're doing is it actually
pure
do you have hidden agendas you say one
thing you do something else but again
does it match and this is one of the
beautiful things for me in monkhood
because this is what we train
every single day we
need to take time to be alone
we need to take time to reflect and make
sure we're congruent
what we think about
what we
speak
what we talk about
and then also our actions
is it pure
so for me every night every day i try to
make sure
what you're doing
is it
is your intention
pure and in this moment i can say
for me
it is
um it is because
there's a lot of people suffering
um my whole life i always felt
that i didn't fit in
i didn't belong why did i do
so many different things
being born in laos
moving at a young age to california at
the age of five
selling real estate
then doing
hip-hop then working as a therapist
then running businesses
then becoming a monkin my whole life i
couldn't quite fit in
and i didn't understand why did i have
to go through all these experiences but
for the first time for me
it just made sense
because before nothing made sense
but now through the different
types of experiences the variety of
experiences both personally
both professionally
then it gives me an opportunity when i
do my work now i'm in the monastery i
can bring this wisdom out and language
in a way like i said that people can
actually hear it that they can interpret
it and use it otherwise it's pointless
it's so deep but we don't get it and i
don't know how to use it so it doesn't
make sense and i think i have a cultural
context
and
out of like i said out of gratitude
for
my own experience and having peace it
took a very long time to get to this
point i just want to share
these kind of things because there's
someone out there who is suffering and i
just think
if it can
decrease
someone's amount of suffering
someone's amount of trying to find
answers then here it is
i hope it helps you so with that being
said just tying in
uh the things that we learned from the
monastery of just keep your eyes on your
own bowl just keep looking at yourself
looking to make sure that your
intentions are pure
and if it is genuinely pure i say don't
worry about anything just close your
eyes
put your head rest your head on your own
pillow sleep in a sea of merit smile and
continue the next day rule number nine
consume good content with dr daniel
allman some people call cnn the crisis
news network because what they're doing
is they're doing headlines to make you
pay attention which is
not good for you it is wearing out your
adrenal glands they produce stress
hormones
pornography is the same way actually
studies have shown it shrinks your
frontal lobes
you know
what you bring in
it helps determine how your brain works
and so if you're watching the same sort
of television shows all the time and
you're not learning anything new or
you're on the internet doing the same
things
that's not good for your brain the more
you use it the more you can use it and
rule number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus clips is be in charge
with mel robbins drive that's this puppy
right here this is what you want this is
your prefrontal cortex drive is the mode
where you're in charge of your thoughts
okay it's where you are fully awake
you are present and you are driving your
thoughts and actions when you're doing
that
your prefrontal cortex is active the
prefrontal cortex is the part of the
brain that you need in order to learn
new behavior
in order to do something difficult in
order to do something uncertain in order
to do strategic thinking so i'm going to
give you an example so i'm a righty if i
were to try to write with my left hand
like louis is going to torture me and
tie my hand behind my back and make me
like do this i could do it
it would look like i was riding with my
foot
and if lewis came up to me and said hey
mel you want some bulletproof coffee i'd
be like louis i'm trying to concentrate
i can't do this
my prefrontal cortex would be el fuego
because it is
firing on all cylinders to communicate
to my hand new behavior
so
the thing that's cool about that
is that you can use a simple trick
the moment you feel yourself hesitate
the moment you've got one of those
moments where you know that you need to
this is that moment that lewis talks to
you about where you got to step outside
of your comfort zone and you've got to
lean into your passion and you've got to
really take some risks and you've got to
feel the fear and you've got to do it
anyway
that's the moment where you just woke up
and now you got a decision to make are
you going to drift back into the habits
or are you going to awaken your
prefrontal cortex and drive forward and
focus and do something new
you're never going to accomplish
anything great if you're coming from a
place of negativity if you are just
complaining and negative and blaming
other people you're never gonna
accomplish anything it's just not gonna
happen you can't create amazing things
from a negative spot
it means that you have zero
resourcefulness because there's no hope
and so you need to flip it now i'm gonna
give you a wild mind trick that that i
use that maybe is a little too weird
duck for you but i want to test it on
you because if if one of you picks it up
it'll dramatically change your life it's
my philosophy of changing negative
situations and doing a quick mind trick
in my head to say it's the best
so whenever i'm hit with a negative
situation something that is beyond my
control something that i can't do
anything about i will complain i will be
unhappy i'll be negative for eight to 24
seconds
and then i'll tell myself
it's the best that this is the best
thing that happened to me and then i'll
figure out why it's the best so as an
example i'm on an airplane i'm coming
from vancouver to l.a i'm speaking at an
event in la i'm on a flight it's a five
hour flight i get on this is really
smelly dude next to me really smelly guy
i he probably hadn't been on you know in
a shower in a couple days probably had
multiple transfers and stopovers and i
have empathy i'm not i'm not pissed at
him i'm pissed at the situation right
i'm sure he's normally a nice smelling
guy and takes care of himself but in
this situation
he was super smelly and i had to deal
with it so what am i going to do i got a
five hour flight what are my options i
can
not go
you know i could miss my flight and then
not do my presentation i could sit on
the airplane and be upset for the next
five hours and then be upset for the
rest of the day and allow this minor
situation to own me and to be better
than me and ruin my entire day or i
could say this is the best
and that's what i did for around eight
to 24 seconds i'm sitting there trying
to figure out
my options what options do i have how
can i do how can i fix this there's no
options i'm screwed and then i'm upset
you know i'm upset this sucks come on
really this is what i have to deal with
the next five hours and then
this is the best
and what do i do
yep
breathe it in breathe it in give it to
me because this is making me stronger
this is the best this is actually the
best why because it's my chance to show
myself what i'm made of that this smelly
dude is not going to own me that i am
stronger than a little bit of smell on
an airplane and that the next time i get
faced with a similar situation i'm able
to handle it it's easy it rubs off me i
think that's how you actually build
self-confidence
that's how you actually build
self-esteem because when it's easy
it's easy winning a race against
three-year-olds is easy doesn't mean
anything you're not gonna clap that up
yay i beat a bunch of three-year-olds
but when it's hard
and you try that's when you actually
build self-esteem
and so flip it flip it in your mind flip
it this is the best whatever negative
situation is in front of you right now
tell yourself it's the best let me give
you another example i'm on a keto diet
six days a week saturdays eat what i
want and sunday to friday i'm on a keto
diet eating super healthy you know all
all avocados and vegetables and some
fish and
we're traveling right now and i'm doing
a 90-day tour across the country and i
told myself i want to come back
in better shape in lower weight than
when i left it's easy for me to stay
consistent at home but when i travel
it's always been my vice when i travel
for a couple days i'll just veg out eat
whatever i want frappuccinos down and
everything it's like yeah sugar
i can't do that for 90 days because i
come back a giant tub so i needed to say
okay you know what here's a challenge
this is my chance to prove myself this
is my chance to show myself what i'm
made of i want to come back weighing
less than when i'd left
and so we're visiting all these cities
and there's tons of great food in every
city right and and i want to look at the
food
and i want to smell it
i want it i want to look at it
and i'm stronger than you every grocery
store that we go into i love going down
the sugar aisle i love going down the
snack i love seeing the klondike reese's
pieces bars i love seeing the doritos i
love seeing them and i love smelling
them whenever i can and just knowing
that i'm stronger i think if you
eliminate the junk food from your house
and you're on a diet it actually makes
you weaker you're training yourself that
you're not capable of resisting and so
there's junk all over the place here
yeah let me show you look here we go
look we just finished awesome junk but
we got right here right here on the
kitchen counter we've got
fudge and more fudge and then
whatever those things are pineapples and
then some some fudge sea salt caramels
just lying out
right in here we got doritos we got look
at this this is gonna kill me look this
is york peppermint patties you kidding
me i wanna eat that entire bag right now
what else
let's go to the third drawer look at
this we got we got sticker bites we got
i'm gonna i could eat this entire bag
right now i'm so hungry we got
we got raisins right chocolate covered
raisins are you kidding me this stuff is
amazing i can't wait i want to eat all
of it and here's what i do when they
come home look at this this one here
this dark chocolate
can you help me open this because i'm
filming
danny
[Music]
so here's the thing here's what i would
love if i wanted to eat this here's what
i would do here's what i would do i
would open it up like this
i just smell it
just smell it and know that i'm stronger
than these sea salt caramels now this
actually pisses me off because i don't
like dark chocolate i can't stand the
smell
and so it smells nasty to me but
i wanted to smell good i wanted to smell
good i want to smell i wanted to be
right here on top of the counter in
front of my face
right doritos i want it right in front
of my face i have a giant bag of doritos
at my home in my office because readers
are my weakness
because damn the doritos
because the doritos aren't stronger than
me
right that smelly guy on the airplane
he's not stronger than me i'm capable of
doing that i'm capable of doing more and
so i love that and maybe that's a little
crazy and when i tell people that story
they say well doesn't that deplete your
your willpower because you only have a
certain amount of willpower for the day
and if you force yourself through that
you're going to deplete your willpower
and then other decisions become more
difficult and uh i get it logically but
for me
maybe it's just the mind trick coming to
play because that makes me stronger i
want more of it i love myself more
because of that i love it it gives me
more energy doesn't take away my
willpower it creates more willpower for
myself and i can't wait to dive into all
that stuff on a saturday but when when
nina and danny are coming back with all
this food i want to smell it i want to
look i want to love it i want my mouth
to water even just thinking about the
doritos right now my mouth is watering
so much and i love so much about myself
that i'm not diving into it and so
changing your identity
that i'm the kind of person who rises to
a challenge who when it's difficult i
crush it i jump into it i love it i
think when you can do that
you're much more likely to go off and
accomplish your goals i think when you
do that you're much more able to handle
adversity in your life and just that
quick mindset shift just that quick
trick into your brain
every single time you find yourself
being negative being complaining being
upset tell yourself it's the best this
is my chance to show myself and the
world
what i'm made of let's go bring me your
doritos bring me your smelly man i got
this i'm ready
you're ready too it's the best is more
worrying about the future you can make
decisions from a place of really instead
of like you know rush decisions and like
i have to make this decision and you
you're not very clear about it when you
can take a step back and become the
observer
you make decisions with a different
level of awareness with a different
clarity and therefore
better decisions i mean i think in the
very beginning when i was going through
my severe anxiety and panic attacks
i actually
went into like you know i don't know if
you guys ever heard about vipassana
which is like a 10-day like intense
meditation um
i actually do like seven days and go in
silence and just meditate for seven days
and with that a lot of stuff comes up
obviously when you're not talking you
realize how much the monkey mind is
trying to take control because that's
the job of the mind right it's to kind
of it's like a friend told me this once
he says gisele the mind is an instrument
don't let it play you
so it's it's a really powerful thing to
remember to be just
just remember that you know that that is
that's the job of the mind is to hold on
to things and to to kind of attach to
things and it's your job to say i choose
this thought and i don't choose that and
i you know because whatever you give
energy to is what grows i actually have
a chapter in my book that it talks about
that is like you know where your energy
goes is what grows and it's like we have
to choose
where we put our energy in because
that's where we're going to manifest so
it's it's
the the more consciously and we can make
those choices and where we're letting
our mind go the better is going to be
for us do you find your meditation
practice also makes you more kind of
outward focused on the world
i think it just gives you a different
kind of awareness i think you see things
from a different place i think
everything slows down and you become
more
conscious of i think of everything
because when you meditate what you do is
like you become
you become silent and i think there's a
in especially in our society today
everything has happened so fast i mean i
remember when i was a kid you know there
was no cell phones like even when i
moved to japan i had to use my the
calling cars to call my mom and be like
you know you got one dollar left and i
you know i called my mom like once a
month from japan because there was no
you know 1994
you know 1995
and and i think you know someone who
calls the house and you're like wait a
minute i'll get the message from my mom
you know i remember when the phones came
out and they had actually the message
that you can leave a message before that
you couldn't so you had like a
notepad and a pencil next to the phone
to leave the message and i think it was
in a way so great because you know
people could do their job and then could
go home and they would have
conversations with dinner table with
their family and they would if people
couldn't catch them at work they would
have to wait to the next day and now i
think with this kind of speed up process
where you're available 24 7
i think is is really creating a lot more
anxiety so i think even more so it's
important to have the moments if like
you said you know a few times a day i
don't think you need to go for like
seven you know every person or like five
days maybe sometimes you do if you have
a specific thing you're dealing with but
if it would be good if every day you can
check in you know if he's two minutes in
a car ride if it's five minutes in the
morning when you wake up if it's before
you go to bed if it's before an
important meeting just to
take a moment you know go go into going
go anywhere take you know focus on your
breath
deep breathing and just allow yourself
to
you know to kind of decompress i think
it's essential to be able to deal with
the amount of pressure we have in our
society today i mean i don't know how
else i mean i couldn't do it without it
when i see myself getting like kind of
like
ants in my pants and i feel like a
little bit like agitated and i can't
really
i'm like you know this is a good moment
for me to take a you know five minutes
and just go in word and i come out of it
just
i don't know if it's because i i allow
myself to breathe deeply and i and i can
really feel
myself getting back into my body because
i think a lot of times when the anxiety
and all those things comes like if you
notice you're not breathing
you're outside of your body everything
becomes very hectic and then if you can
just center yourself just take that
moment is a gift
that costs nothing you know is a gift is
the biggest gift i think you know that
you can just
all it takes is the awareness to say you
know this is the mo this is
i'm gonna take this five minutes or two
minutes or however long i have right now
to just sit in silence and
and breathe i usually like to compare
mindfulness to a remote control
imagine you could press pause on a
thought
imagine you could use that time to just
reflect
take a step back
observe
imagine you could fast forward to
something in the past learn from it
straight away
and then press play again when you felt
comfortable does that sound like a good
idea would that feel good
mindfulness really allows you to find
that clarity space
time
so that you can actually
navigate your mind
and not just be led by it
to wherever it may flow we spend so much
of our life lost in the maze
and lost in the details that we often
don't be able to get that bird's eye
view so we've just shown how actually
one of the biggest things the greatest
things about mindfulness is just that
slight
three steps backwards so that we can
look at our challenges look at our
situations when we need to with a bit
more space one of the second things i
hear often is that mindfulness is for
those who are stressed or meditation is
for those who are struggling with mental
health the incredible thing is harvard
stanford you name it they've done
incredible scientific studies around how
mindfulness
actually helps people become more
focused become more creative
and be able to apply their attention
anywhere and everywhere they like
and one of my favorite things about that
is i often say that silicon valley has
done more for mindfulness than the monks
have
because silicon valley have been such
great proponents of mindfulness and
their practice of it with their
employees who have to be creative who
have to be inventing the next steps when
you enter the yoga institute that small
little gate we have written there
please close the door
mindfulness is yoga
whatever you are doing see that your
mind is present there and you do
you see human mind is very intelligent
mind highly developed mind so that mind
is going anywhere and everywhere it
doesn't stay at one place that's the
whole problem with us
because we are highly developed by an
animal mind is simple
when an animal
is hungry animal goes in search for food
and mind doesn't go anywhere else
because it's hungry so the need is there
otherwise he will not survive mind is
focused on that totally focused
concentration is perfected animals
natural but human human needs are so
many
and their needs are so many and not that
need like animal birth or death type
if you can't eat food for you will be
struggling
nothing like that in human life and so
mind goes anywhere and everywhere
usually what happens is when we suffer
thoroughly thoroughly well in life
then we think of changing
till then we have that laziness in us
let it be a cat difference does it make
that type of a personality yoga would
never accept
you would see to it that if you are
doing you do it very well under pain and
suffering there is some little
resolution in mind that now you will not
do this you will do this sometimes
person is talking talking and talks
something which is not so good
and then she realizes or he realizes
that i should not have spoken this
well so now you become mindful
is it required to speak then only open
your mouth otherwise don't open
this little thinking has to go deeper
into us so this way we become little
alert and aware
mindfulness means awareness
so first of all form a habit that
whatever you are doing you see to it
that you m your mind is there
with you when you are doing anything let
it be brushing your teeth or eating your
food or talking to each other or doing
anything or even resting sleeping your
mind should be there with you while
sleeping really present to the moment
yes
you have come to the point that you
learn to be in present moment and that
will help you
to do your job well so unless you are
mindful
you will not be able to do any work well
in life this habit where your body is
your mind should be
where your mind is your emotion should
be
where your emotions are your faith
should be
faith means confidence
willpower that should be then you do
your work
so
either you are doing work mechanically
without mind
or mind is there but emotions are not
there you do it very in a dry way like
machine
now everything should be present body
mind emotion and faith
all these four things together and you
are working
that is mindfulness
so we should form such habit
let's do few things but do it
systematically very well
so we have one technique in yoga we
always say that at night before going to
bed just reflect
how did you spend your day
you should know how did you spend your
day and what did you do so right from
till now earlier one hour before what
did you do still before what did you do
till your morning when you got up and
then you realize there are certain
things which you don't even remember
i know one boy he came to me he had
definitely he was wearing something else
in the morning he was wearing something
else but he's
telling me and sanji i don't know
whether i have taken bath or not mind is
not there only while taking bath while
eating food while going here and there
that has that is the biggest problem now
now the mind has become so mechanical
with all these machines and gadgets in
our hand
that little
toy which we have always the computer
and the
phone mobile phone
that we are not using our mind
everything is used by the autopilot that
autopilot
that is very
wrong when it comes to self-development
see to it that you are not so much
dependent on anything
but
dependent on yourself so be very very
clear when mind is with you you will
never go to past
you will rather
remain in present from past you learn
history is for learning you the history
of anything you just learn from that
don't remain
in past remaining in past means you are
your progress is going down
as far as future is concerned don't
think about it
past will always bring tears in your
eyes and future will always bring fear
in your what will happen what will
happen
remain in present that will bring cheer
in your life
there are four things which you are
supposed to do in a day
one is doing your duty
all your responsibilities and duties you
must do
second is earning money that is your
duty
third is rest recreation hobbies
equally important that you should do
and fourth is some selfless work
something for others
and so these are four types of work so
where your spiritual growth will occur
so these four types of things you should
do so become mindful have i done all
these four things no then plan your day
next day better and do it better so try
and live life like that and it would be
beautiful in a day
from the moment i leave the sleep time
for you
that also needs to be considered but we
believe that from the moment you come
awake till the moment you fall asleep
how many moments and how many actions
and how many thoughts and how many
emotions
or how much percentage of it do you
conduct consciously
this will determine the state of your
revolution right now
if you conduct it consciously
you will do it in a certain way if
you're going about compulsively
you will look like any other creature
yes
you look like just any other creature
not any different
once you do things compulsively
only when you conduct it consciously you
seem to be
on the peak of evolution on this planet
not otherwise
so you can gauge by yourself i don't to
pass i don't want to pass a judgment on
anybody
from the moment you come awake till the
time you go asleep fall asleep
how much percentage of time are you
conducting your body your mind your
emotion your energy and your actions
consciously
if you are less than one percent you
know there's a lot of work to do and i
would
tell you
the if i have to speak frankly more than
ninety percent is less than one percent
less than well below one percent more
than ninety percent of the people
those ten percent who do little more
than one percent suddenly they look like
such graceful beings
just from tomorrow morning
you want to do it from tomorrow morning
or now
from this moment till you fall asleep
just see
how much of you can you conduct
consciously all aspects of you
your body your actions your mind your
thoughts your emotions your energies
everything
to what extent can you conduct it
consciously you see
if you conduct this consciously for five
minutes
by tomorrow morning people will bow down
to you
without knowing why they're doing
so that's evolution
and it's something you can do if you
just say it's me not something else you
will evolve because once you become
human
you have enough awareness and
consciousness to evolve consciously when
you were a monkey you did not decide i
will become human being
nature
just pushed you on but now you're
conscious enough to decide i want to
evolve from where i am
to whatever is possible
just just try
just maintain five minutes manage your
life consciously today you will see
tomorrow morning how you will be
you will be shining believe me
mindfulness is a translation of a pali
term and pali was the vernacular
language in which the teachings of the
historical buddha were first written
down
and the word in poly is saki and it
connotes awareness attention and
remembering
and the awareness and attention part are
pretty much the way we use them in
english to be aware and to pay attention
but the remembering is different it's
not about remembering what you had for
breakfast or for that matter even
remembering childhood trauma it's about
remembering to be aware and pay
attention at each moment of our day
now there's a um a scholar of the
ancient text named john dunn at emory
university
and he raised the following criticism he
said
you know if you could imagine a sniper
poised on top of a building getting
ready to take out an innocent victim
that sniper would be very aware
very attentive and every time his mind
wandered from the task at hand he'd be
zeroing right in on it and john said i
don't think that's exactly the attitude
you're trying to develop in yourselves
as psychotherapists nor the attitude
you're trying to cultivate in your
patients or clients something's missing
here
and what's missing is a sense of
non-judgment acceptance kindness and
friendliness now there are some scholars
who say that's included in sati but the
important point is that this
non-judgment or acceptance is a skill
unto itself and which takes some work to
cultivate let me show you what i mean
join me in looking at this fellow
and just take in the picture of him
and see what emotion arises as you look
at him
and raise your hand of what you feel is
a sense of harsh and critical judgment
[Music]
we can talk afterwards if so but you
know most of us look at him and feel
something like oh
right okay now even if he pees and poops
at the wrong time in the wrong place
even if he doesn't listen to
instructions we can understand he's
young he's a puppy he needs training
right
now when you take up mindfulness
practices most of us one of the first
things we see is that our mind does
actually pee and poop at the wrong time
in the wrong place and it doesn't listen
to instructions at all that is quite
quite unruly and the same kind of loving
attitude that we would cultivate toward
that puppy that's what we're going to
try to cultivate toward whatever arises
in our consciousness including
depressive feelings anxious feelings
physical pain and the like there's a
well-known zen teaching story
about a
horrible sadistic general
who had come to town this was in
medieval japan
and they were
burning crops and burning buildings and
killing the able-bodied boys and men and
they were raping women it was horrible
and this general really wanted to
vanquish the town's folks and he caught
wind that they respected their zen
master
so he took his horse and he rode up the
hillside into the main hall of the zen
temple and they're sitting on the
meditation cushion is this little old
man the zen master
and the general takes his bloody sword
and he holds it over the zen master he
says don't you realize i can run you
through the sword without blinking an
eye
and little man looks up and he says yes
and i sir can be run through with a
sword without blinking an eye
and it said that at that moment the
general becomes disoriented and leaves
town
now it's not always going to work as a
military intervention but it speaks to
how these practices develop our capacity
to be with discomfort and not to have to
escape it once we've practiced
mindfulness for a while and spent time
dropping out of the thought stream and
staying at the sensory level let's say
the anger comes up and all i experience
is the body tensing up heart rate
increasing respiration increasing blood
pressure well you don't feel blood
pressure but body temperature increasing
and perhaps the thought
right coming in passing like a cloud in
the sky perhaps the image of
decapitating my former friend dancing
through the minds of high but it's all
seen as a kind of impersonal process of
mental contents arising and passing and
when we can experience it that way
we get much less caught in it and it is
much easier to let it come and go
detachment from any feeling emotion or
even sometimes expectation
to the day it's not feeling anything and
allowing yourself to feel things even
when they're good you know a lot of
people have done so much work in their
life to blot out negative emotion that
they're not letting in positive emotion
or so many people feel like they've been
failing so much in their lives they
don't have a connection to the things
when they do succeed so they're not
integrating success
right they might have a good thing a
good series of things happens to them
but they don't feel them they don't
allow themselves to take that success in
that that win in it and really
internalize and say wow you know i did
that
and since that moment of satisfaction or
pride to doing something amazing they
never allow themselves any of the
positive emotions of life and they don't
allow those imposing emotions to stick
to settle in that's why one of the first
things that a psychologist will do in
working with a new patient is make sure
at the end of the day they start
journaling positive things that happen
throughout their day it's been
scientifically proven that you can
essentially just start a gratitude
journal and lift up your level of
happiness in life why because now you're
paying attention for the things that do
bring you positive emotion and happiness
in life you're recording them you're
writing them down it's physicalizing
that memory and feeling it and sensing
it and allowing it to come in
so try that
you know if you feel like you've been
detached from emotion in life it's time
to allow that back in to allow yourself
to feel passionate and excited about
things again to allow yourself to get
dorked out about a new learning
opportunity a new thing you're gonna see
to allow yourself to say you know what i
did that good for me to have a sense of
pride about some things you know you
deserve that you did some good things
and it's also allowing yourself not to
be detached from negative things you
know so many people are so scared to to
experience a negative thing that
it's like they've never developed any
strength or capability of dealing with
those things right do you know anybody
who can't handle conflict they're always
running from conflict because they've
always detached from that emotion oh i'm
scared i'm scared
part of the way that we become mature
and enlightened adults is we start to
face the things that we are fearful of
or we are scared of and we allow
ourselves to feel it and to sense it
it's okay to feel the fear it's okay to
feel uncomfortable about something it's
okay to feel vulnerable it's okay to
feel what other people might call
negative or scary or uncertain emotions
because the more comfort that you start
to have with uncomfortable emotions the
more comfort you have with uncomfortable
situations the more you start to develop
more consciousness about how to deal
with them right and the only way you're
going to develop comfort with them is
allowing yourself to accept that and
acknowledge wow this is the feeling i'm
having right now about this why am i
feeling this way is this how i want to
feel will this add or contribute here is
there anything i do to shift or generate
a new emotion that would be more
positive or healthy for me that's
consciousness
so you have to be you don't have to you
can't do that if you're detached from
every emotion or every opportunity and
every experience that comes into your
life you have to feel again this is a
quote from william james he said the
faculty of voluntarily bringing back
a wandering attention over and over
again
is the very root of judgment
character and will
an education which should improve this
faculty would be the
education
par excellence
and then he went on to say but it is
easier to define this ideal
than to give practical directions for
bringing it about
i think if william james had
more
intimate familiarity with the
contemplative traditions he would have
instantaneously seen
that these were methods that can be used
to educate attention
a recent study published in a major
scientific journal used smartphones to
sample people's experience in the world
and they asked people several questions
they asked them what are you doing right
now
and i had to check off on a list of
activities and the second question is
where is your mind right now is it
focused on what you're doing or is it
focused elsewhere and the third question
that they ask them is how happy are you
or unhappy are you right at this moment
and what was found in this study this
was a sample of thousands of people
what was found is that the average
american adult
spends 47 percent of her or his waking
life not paying attention to what
they're doing
folks we could do better
even if it's just the smidgen better
we could do better
and when they were not paying attention
to what they're doing
they reported that they were unhappy
so let me end
with just telling a little story
i was in dharmsala with his holiness the
dalai lama on one occasion and
during a tea break
i was with him with just one other
person so just the three of us and there
was this the person who was with me was
this really crazy japanese scientist
and the japanese scientist leans over
and he said to his holiness your
holiness can you please tell us the time
in your life when you were the most
happy
and i thought that was real that's a
really interesting question and
just like that his holiness said right
now our repeated experiences shape our
brain
does this remind you of anything right
it's exactly what this monk told me what
we practice becomes stronger
everything that we practice every single
moment matters these are brains from
harvard i think that makes them a little
more special
and basically sarah lazar did this
wonderful early research and what she
found is that
meditators
the actual parts of their brain that
have to do with attention concentration
emotional intelligence compassion those
parts of the brain actually get stronger
bigger it's what it's called cortical
thickening
and that this thickening is correlated
with practice
what we practice gets stronger
so the way i like to think of it is we
have these super high ways of habits
and they're just like they're
well-grooved pathways in our brain right
they just
you know they're what we automatically
do
and what mindfulness is helping us start
to do is to kind of like
build kind of like i think of it as like
digging a country road you're you're
clearing all the brambles in your brain
you're creating this new neural pathway
that's like oh i'm gonna actually do it
with compassion this time or with a
little more patience or a little more
presence and so instead of going down
that same super superhighway of habit
we're shifting and we're going down a
different pathway
and every single time that we do this
we're strengthening that pathway so that
eventually that pathway becomes the
habit people talk about being present
being in the moment being in the now and
you see all these cute little instagram
quotes floating around be in the moment
be in the now no one tells you how the
hell to do it
right you can't be in the moment if you
can't concentrate
the ability to be present
stems from being able to be concentrated
and put your awareness on something or
someone
for a certain period of time exactly
yeah so how can i be in the moment here
with you if i can't concentrate so
everybody talks about the end product
which is be in the moment be present be
mindful mindfulness right being sold
like
you know bottled water everywhere
but they don't teach you concentration
you can't be mindful unless you
concentrate
mindfulness is a byproduct of
concentration in understanding the mind
the simple way i teach people this is
there's two things you need to
understand you need to understand is the
mind and there's awareness so let's
define both of them i define the mind as
a vast space with many different areas
within it one area of the mind is anger
one air is jealousy one there is
happiness food sex photography so many
different areas of the mind and then you
have awareness i define awareness as a
glowing ball of light so imagine an orb
or a ball of light that can float around
so
your mind doesn't move but it's your
awareness that travels to different
areas of the mind so you hear people say
all the time i have a monkey mind or my
mind travels a lot my mind's all over
the place technically i believe from my
experience that's false the mind doesn't
move but it's awareness that's traveling
within the mind so your awareness can go
to the happy area of the mind it can go
to the sad area of the mind it can go to
the scientific area of the mind your
goal is to control your awareness that
ball of light and determine where it
goes in your mind
and your ability to keep that awareness
in one area of the mind for an extended
period of time
is your ability to concentrate so if
you're reflecting on something you're
meditating on something it's your
awareness it's in one area of the mind
and you're holding it there long enough
to actually gain knowledge from it i
know you talk about reading just now
right someone opens a book is reading
their ability to keep their awareness on
that page
that ball of light on that page right
allows them to gain information
from the book but if they can't keep it
there long enough
they don't gain anything
right so understanding awareness and the
mind is the precursor to learning how to
concentrate the simplest thing you can
do is practice doing one thing at a time
which is very difficult for people
so if you're speaking with someone give
that person your undivided attention
keep your awareness on them so imagine
your awareness again as a ball of light
i'm speaking to jim my awareness drift
away i bring it back it drips away i
bring it back so i use gym as an
opportunity to practice concentrating so
if you have a spouse or a partner or
loved one that you see every day or you
speak to every day then use that person
as an opportunity to practice
concentration every time you speak with
your spouse could be two hours
throughout the day
give your spouse your undivided
attention now you have two hours of
practice in concentration the most
amazing thing
in your life
for most people in the normal
state of consciousness
uh and normal means
somewhat
or very insane
in the normal state of consciousness the
present moment is usually overlooked
habitually
unconsciously
people have been conditioned
to overlook
the most important thing
there ever is because
your entire life
consists of
the present moment
there never has been
anything else everything happened in the
present moment and when you remember it
it's the present moment
and when you think about the future
which of course never arrives as the
future
it can only arrive as the present moment
but people live as if the present moment
were
undesirable
or an obstacle or they actively dislike
it
and some people habitually live actively
disliking the is-ness of the present
moment usually when you talk about them
now then people
it's usually associated with
okay
the first thing that appears then in
your awareness perhaps is
your surroundings
and that's already a great step
into the now it's the first important
step into the now
to become aware
of whatever surrounds you the space that
surrounds you wherever you may be and
whatever
takes place in that space
and you may notice when you become aware
of those sense perceptions because it's
through sense perceptions that you
become aware of whatever
happens around you
that involves visual auditory and such
to some extent the other senses too
the main ones being
visual and
seeing and hearing
so as we enter the now we become more
aware of our
surroundings it's the first
step into the now
and now when you do that and let's do
that now just not as not thinking i'm
going to practice now not just become
more aware of your surroundings no
practice
and it's not a doing it's just
it
an awareness arises of
this room
the people in this room the man sitting
on the chair talking the lights
beautiful arrangement there
and that is
the space of now so you can so what the
word to use is you acknowledge
what
is and close to acknowledging you go a
little bit deeper
you appreciate
what is
what before
you probably overlooked completely
and
that's already a wonderful thing and
there are some people
who are not yet ready to go any deeper
than that and that's fine
it's enough to just go two steps into
the now well let's let's call it three
people like the idea of steps
let's call it step one you become more
aware of your surroundings
step
two you acknowledge
ah
and with the acknowledgement comes a
sense of the goodness of the ways in
which life manifests continuously around
you there is an aliveness in everything
even in the middle of a city you might
say oh i prefer the forest or the beach
or the mountains but even in the middle
of the city
whatever happens all the movements in
the middle of a city
are manifestations of life life
manifesting as human beings running
around as cars as houses buildings and
noise and so on and there's also
something there that is fine it's your
an acknowledgement of
life
and then comes an appreciation oh
you you might see something that you
before had not appreciated the sky for
example
how many times are you aware of the sky
and say oh
and it's beautiful
and even a cloudy sky there's always
this light filtering through the clouds
now you might notice when you become
aware of the
what i call the surface of now which are
the sensory perceptions that reveal the
world to you
[Music]
already a shift in consciousness happens
because now you're not thinking as much
you cannot be very much aware of sense
perception and really be looking at the
sky or at a tree or a flower or a street
scene
and be thinking a lot you have to be
really there as the presence
for example now
so you simply acknowledge
the totality of this room
and that's beautiful
and then
you go a little deeper still
the next step
takes you deeper and you can ask
yourself
what else is there to them now apart
from the things that arise in my sense
perception what else is there say
anything else is that what the now is
what appears in the now
no
it's what appears in the now but it's
not yet the now
so to become aware of the present moment
to become aware of sense perceptions is
an important step and some people are so
out of touch with their surroundings
they are never
where they are they are in their the
stream of their thinking as you become
more aware of your sense perceptions
your alertness and when i say alertness
don't let that be just a conceptual
thing alertness needs to be something
that you can only can only know what
alert awareness is by experiencing alert
awareness you cannot understand
conceptually what alert awareness is
and everybody here
i would say
can
knows already and can verify in their
own experience
the difference between
being absorbed in your the inner being
identified with the voice in your head
which is habitual compulsive thinking
and
being in a state of alert awareness
every time we have a thought we make a
chemical and and if you have
uh an unlimited thought you will feel
unlimited and if you have a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits
that signal another part of the brain to
release peptides or chemical messengers
that signal hormonal centers
and when we get that arousal from the
thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
it turns out that
the emotions that are created from the
thoughts are the signaling mechanisms of
the body thoughts of the language of the
brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel
creates our state of being
so it turns out that the thoughts based
in the stress hormones
based in survival those are the thoughts
that begin to push the genetic buttons
that create disease in other words
a person wakes up in the morning
and the brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems
and those problems are memories that are
etched in the brain that are connected
to certain people certain objects
certain things at certain times and
places so if you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny the moment you think about your
problems you're thinking in the past
right
now every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them because
we've experienced them so the moment you
remember your problems
now you feel unhappy now you feel
anxious now you feel fear
so the moment we feel those emotions it
takes a thought and a feeling
a memory or an image an emotion
a stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past now the body
is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion
and the emotion that person's
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's in that environmental
condition
so if the environment signals the gene
and that's the truth
and the end product of an experiences in
the environment is an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and if you keep signaling
the same genes you start down regulating
the gene to make cheaper proteins and
the body begins to break down now that's
an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is
the brain checks in with the body and
says yeah you're feeling pretty
miserable you're suffering and we tend
to generate more thoughts
equal to the feeling that we have
and so then we get caught in this loop
of thinking and feeling so if we can't
think
greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking
then we're thinking in the past right
and so we call that
the familiar past and then a person gets
going in the day and they start thinking
oh i gotta see this person i gotta go to
that meeting i hate doing this and now
they get in their routine
and a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person running through the
same routine every single day is on
autopilot and their body's now dragging
them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists
is the sweet spot of the generous
present moment that is when the body and
mind are free from those conditions so
along with those emotions that influence
the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled
they start getting more afraid more
anxious more depressed and now the body
is literally being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion
and in a sense they become addicted to
the life they don't even like
and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
and the bodies sing you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you get in traffic and you're
angry then at 11 o'clock you check your
emails and you're really judgmental and
frustrated the body's saying well you've
been doing this for the last 20 years
you're just going to stop today so now
the body which has been conditioned
emotionally to be the mind wants to
return back to its familiar territory to
the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so
that's when the person makes the same
choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling okay i'll complain
just so i can feel suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
and step into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process
first of all is not making the same
choice as you did day before
and here's the payoff
you got to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so
the thoughts that they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and your tweeting and your
instagramming and facebook and whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm gonna feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then
if you say then you're not going to live
in the familiar future familiar past or
predictable future you're not going to
think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do you you
labor
uh for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and check your cell
phone or have a cup of coffee and you
become aware that it's on autopilot and
wants to do that and you say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now
that's greater than the program and if
the person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're
they're working and lowering the volume
of that emotion the more they lower the
volume of that emotion the more they're
going to take their attention off that
person and problem and they're going to
take their power back there's going to
be a break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else as you may know i came
from a pretty rough and tough background
in my childhood and i wasn't used to
hanging around with successful people or
being part of the world of the wealthy
if i hadn't discovered
how to retrain my brain to change my
results chances are i would have ended
up in jail or the morgue
now for me i had a very successful
mentor named alan brown
and alan took it upon himself to show me
many of the secrets that wealthy people
understood which allowed them to have
what i think is almost a magical ability
to set and achieve goals and it can seem
impossible to achieve those same goals
to people who don't understand how the
process works
and so as part of my training
alan had me do something
i think it's very interesting what he
had me do is he had me write down
one
extremely specific goal
with a date associated with it of when i
would achieve it
but then he asked me to do something
that seemed i guess pretty boring since
i was 19 years old and it seemed
redundant to do it over and over again
but he had me read this goal
every single day
with my fingers scrolling on the words
of the page
he told me
to do my best to feel the words with my
fingers now i know it may sound crazy
but he wanted me to feel the world the
the words and he wanted me to imagine
that what i had written down
was true and that the goal that i had
written down one goal one date
was becoming a reality for me so he had
me in essence
read
put my fingers across the words and see
myself moving towards those goals and
what he shared with me
is that when you see
read and feel this goal
in this way
you're actually sending an electrical
signal
to your brain from your finger up your
arm to your brain which does what
it makes you much more likely to achieve
this goal
little did he know that what he said
would later be 100
validated by
neuroscientific discoveries
let me explain there is a term in the
brain research the science field that
goes like this
the neurons brain cells that fire
together
wire together
what this means is that when you
activate by hearing seeing running your
finger on your goals
when you activate and wire the different
brain cells together they formulate a
pattern
the more you reinforce that pattern the
more it becomes a strong
automatic pattern in your brain
that causes you to think feel and do
things differently so your reality
changes now on any given day you have 30
40 50 000 thoughts popping up in your
head
some of these thoughts are caused by
internal influences such as your
memories your beliefs
habits that you have
others
are caused by external influences like
texts you receive
facebook cell phones traffic bird flying
across you know the sky uh into your
window
these thoughts cause your mind and even
mind to be scattered all over the place
most of the day with no clear direction
or focus
and so
if you think of your brain
as an organ right
i'm gonna pull my brain from right over
here i've got a brain okay right over
here it's not my brain but it's a brain
if you think of your brain
as an organ that you could put to work
for yourself like a loyal servant
then what you also need to do is you
need to direct it and if you don't it'll
just wander all over the place with no
idea what you actually want
so if your goals are scattered so will
your focus be but as soon as you set a
goal and choose to consistently
and consciously focus on it your brain
realizes that this is important to you
and then what happens is it starts to
automatically notice ways to bring you
things that you want from the
perspective of teaching you how to focus
on it and this is one of the best ways
to activate and create a new pattern in
your
non-conscious brain which you've
probably heard a million times is where
your real power is we tend
to be really really
skeptical questioning doubtful critical
or people coming from the outside
but we're very trusting of the inside
and the inside is what's actually being
hacked right now
and what people can exploit to get to us
we call it the eminem like a really
really strong shell that keeps things
from the outside but once you get in
it's all chocolate
we trust our brain blindly
and more and more
hackers like myself are showing that we
can actually get into your mind and
change some things there
and when we do that you will never
suspect it
years of evolution have taught us to be
skeptical of the outside world but never
to doubt our own mind if you start
doubting your own thoughts it would be
really really difficult to live normal
life
my students made this t-shirt that i
think helps us
understand how difficult it is that says
don't believe everything you think
and that is maybe the take-home message
for my talk today which is what needs to
be changed is that we need to start
doubting our own mind let's do that
experiment in this room you're sitting
here with me right now you're in this
room tomorrow you meet your friends and
your friend says you know it was lovely
that yesterday we were together in the
library
you say no no no yesterday i was
listening to this speaker talking about
the brain i remember the guy says no you
were with me in the library here is a
picture of the two of us in the library
and he shows you a picture of the two of
you
how likely to change your mind to say
you know what
maybe i wasn't listening to a talk in
the morning i was actually in the
library
the reality is that it's very very hard
for you to believe anything if your mind
contradicts that you will think that
you're right
regardless of tons of evidence it comes
to the contrary because we readily
mistrust our own brain our brain has
many many sites and each site has its
own function and it just knows that it
expects some input and outputs to come
and go but it doesn't really know what
other systems are doing for example
if i ask you right now how much is a two
plus five
let's go over all the steps that
happened in your mind for you to get the
answer
first you heard my sound that turned
molecular vibrations in the air into a
concept in your auditory cortex
which you then move to the part of the
brain that does language processing and
there you saw the sentence two plus five
then you had to break it into perceptual
entities so you sent it to a different
system that says okay there's something
called two something called five
something called pass each of them is
its own thing we need to do equation
solving so let's send it to the math
area that's gonna do the crunching and
copy the number seven send it back
another entity is now a sector the
number seven which is being sent to the
language area where you make it into a
word seven and then maybe you send it to
the area of the brain that controls the
mouth and tells them how to move to
state that's just a simplification
of all the systems involved in your
brain when you do the solution to the
question how much is two plus five
now the thing is the system in the
center does not do math it just sends
those
entities and waits for a number
so if someone sat in the middle
and just saw the communication and send
a different answer you would never know
if instead of the number seven coming up
from the one area you would just get the
number nine you would think this is the
answer you would never doubt your own
mind and in fact now
in the world we have more and more
people that have a device
an implant in their brain that can sit
in between and do things for them in the
u.s there's about 40 000 people right
now that have a cheap insider brain for
clinical purposes
usually for clinical depression or
parkinson's disease and this is supposed
to do only one thing
but the reality is that as soon as you
put something digital in your brain
hackers can come in
and start changing things
so not only do you have the problem of
having to be skeptical of the outside
world now you have to ask yourself do i
trust my own mind
and as time goes by more and more people
from silicon valley mainly come to me as
a scientist and say we want to put a
device inside our brain and my
prediction is at some point it's going
to happen
people are going to want
more brain power they're going to want
to be able to access wikipedia from
their mind
to solve much more complex problems than
how much is two plus five in their mind
to maybe speak more languages
intuitively to have better memory
to do high frequency trading
as soon as we see the benefit for that
people are gonna want more and more of
that and as you have a chip inside your
brain the sky describe the limit to what
hackers can do
to get in and change stuff
so
what are we going to do about that
well
the good news is that hackers also gave
us some solutions
hackers know something that i think
would be important for you to know which
is that there is a way to fight
hacking into a system
and that is to doubt the integrity of
the security
you can put all the firewalls all the
antiviruses everything to secure things
from the outside but in the end what
hackers would tell you is that the best
way to defend something
is to say
let's imagine for a second that someone
is already in my system somebody already
hacked into my system what will i do
then imagine if someone is already
hacked into your emails what would you
do
maybe you will change your password
right away maybe when you start looking
at your emails you will say is that
something that really could come from
who it said it is or maybe i should
doubt it and i call and say hey did you
send me this thing
you know
a few days ago was a april 1st which is
also known as april fool
and i was traveling with two of my
friends and i tried to prank them when i
feel fool i told them something and as
soon as i started my prank the first guy
said wait it sounds very suspicious and
today is april 1st i'm gonna listen to
you with some criticism and in many ways
this is what we should do we should
always say
do i actually believe my own thoughts
because in a world
where someone connecting to our brain
we would have a hard time even knowing
if what we think we are is true and the
entire premise of the world right now
relies on you trusting yourself we have
people going to the voting ballot and in
the end they close the curtain and say
now it's only me now i can reach into my
own gut and know what i want and i'm
going to look and dive deep into my
personality and decide if i vote
democrats are republican and i know and
we have senators like the voter always
knows or the customer is always right
or beauty is in the eye of the beholder
or seeing is believing and all of them
assume one thing which is when it goes
into your mind
you can trust it
so solutions
first doubt
always true
didn't change
now
another one
surround yourself with people
that can verify your reality ask
questions do you think that something i
would say more so put yourself next to
people that have opposite opinions
this is really helpful and in fact a
really good game to play
is to say
you know i always was a democrat all my
life i'm about to vote democrats i want
to stop for a second and ask the
question what would need to happen for
me to convince myself to vote the
opposite republicans
the same way i told you in the beginning
to ask yourself what needs to happen for
you to convince yourself that you are
not here with me
if you live in a world where you say
everyone can hack into everything and i
can't trust my own mind
a good idea is to play a game where
every now and then you say let's doubt
everything in my mind and try to create
a new world there are a couple ways to
think about it but i would say just
quick definition a habit is a behavior
that has been repeated enough times to
be performed more or less automatically
so you can do it pretty much on
autopilot
but another way to think about it i
think this is a useful way to define a
habit is that
as you go through life you face
different problems and some of those
problems are big and some of them are
small like you need to tie your shoes
and whenever you face a problem your
brain starts looking for solutions to
that and as you come across solutions to
the recurring problems in life
you start to automate those and so every
morning you wake up and you put your
shoes on and you got this little problem
that you need to solve and pretty soon
after you tie your shoes 100 times or
500 times or a thousand times you can do
it pretty much without thinking
and so that's another way of thinking
about habits is that they're kind of
these like automatic solutions we fall
into for whatever the recurring problems
are we face right behavior that becomes
habituated yeah and you know like there
the interesting thing about this is you
don't necessarily have to have the same
habit to solve a recurring problem like
if you come home from work each day and
you feel stressed and exhausted one
person might
play video games for an hour and that's
a way to resolve that problem so they
get in the habit of doing it they just
walk over the controller they don't
think about it another person might go
for a run for 20 minutes or meditate for
10 minutes third person might smoke a
cigarette and all of those are just
solutions to that problem that you're
facing and
that i think is another powerful lesson
is that your original habit is not
necessarily the optimal one why are
children such great passive learners
they're not trying they're just learning
they're coming home with all sorts of
things sometimes things you don't want
them to come home with
right it's because they have this
element of play and what is play play
isn't just movement although it includes
movement it's giving things everything
you've got but keeping it in perspective
it's that sweet spot of enjoying life
and trying really really hard at it at
the same time it's essentially what we
all
strive for and there are these
incredible cases throughout history
famous scientists because i grew up in a
house where people you know revered
scientists like like richard feynman
nobel prize winner he's most famous for
bongo drumming naked on the roof of
caltech and he became an amazing artist
in his 60s and he developed all sorts of
other skills and he always had this
childlike way of looking at the world he
never let himself get stuck in his ways
never became a curmudgeon and a
remarkable man and that's something that
i if you come away with nothing else i
encourage you to do that you want your
brain to change stay light stay loose
but give it everything you've got every
time we see ourself repetitive okay
right that especially in situations i
know we all can identify those where
whatever we're doing in that repetitive
fashion isn't translating to the results
that we want right if each time this
this this conversation comes up and you
know i react in in one particular way
and i get this con reaction or
repercussion if you will and that
doesn't work for me yet i can't stop
that's usually an indicator that we're
kind of stuck
in in that autopilot so for me it wasn't
an aha light bulb moment for me it was
very gradual it was beginning to use
different tools so for me it was simply
realizing how unconscious i was oh
consciousness great okay so i've learned
what i first learned what does it mean
to be conscious okay being conscious
means being fully present being in a
moment having my senses activated okay
first question asked myself
how how often are you in that state
during your day and my first answer was
i'm not so now i know i don't really
know what consciousness is like so until
i begin to practice that new habit
and settle into now a more conscious
life now by contrast i can understand
consciousness
versus unconsciousness so a lot of us
have to begin to action i guess is the
way i want to simply answer this to
break those habits to give ourselves new
lived experiences to be able to
understand right which was that remnant
of the past and which is the future that
i choose to walk toward
listeners who don't you know yet know
kind of how conscious or unconscious
they are throughout their day we all
walk around with cell phones
best suggestion just set an alarm on
your phone for random times throughout
your day so you might not even
remember by the time the alarm goes off
when that alarm goes off and you oh my
alarm's going off
first ask yourself where was my
attention where's my attention right now
that you know i hear this thing and now
i might zap back in to the current
moment where was it was i worrying about
the argument that i had with my partner
in the morning was i may be worrying
about what's happening tomorrow
was i like me somewhere somewhere else
but i don't really know where i was
and then when i do identify that i was
somewhere else as a lot of us will
using your senses doing exactly like you
said they can be incredibly what we call
grounding because when i'm activating my
senses i've now removed my attention
from wherever else it was and i've
brought it back into my physical body
entering the present moment activating
the prefrontal cortex and actually
different part of our brain from that
subconscious that was probably calling
the shots until you tuned in
firing that up we know that neurons that
fire together wire together right so
we're almost giving ourselves some
mental training and then making it
easier to access that conscious state in
the future so yeah using your senses ask
yourself i'm touching a nice
pillow right here right i'm touching i'm
smelling i'm feeling and now i'm
conscious a lot of us probably will
shift right out of that consciousness
very quickly if we're used to
being in that unconscious autopilot
which is why i say it's a practice we
are bombarded with an avalanche of
information right each and every day and
it is overwhelming right and you must
intend to remember something if you are
going to remember something it's as
simple as that if you forgot a name now
by the way say yes if this is you have
you forgotten a name recently
have you forgotten where you parked your
car have you misplaced things that you
use every single day like you're the
remote control or maybe your phone
have you ever lost your train of thought
have you ever forgot what someone just
said
like maybe something i just said right
and there's a quote from my mentor
his name is dr stephen covey many of you
have read his book seven habits highly
affected people he said most people do
not listen with the intention to
understand most people listen with the
intention to
reply so they're not really
understanding because their their
intention is
they're not they're thinking about how
they're going to respond and one of his
habits was seek first to understand then
to be understood because people don't
care how much you know until they know
how much you care and that's why your
intention matters people could feel your
intention now
how are we defining intention
well in in latin uh intent just
is uh is your aim it is uh it is your
purpose
right it could be defined as a thing
that you intended an aim a plan the
power of intention is is really the
power of of a focused dedicated mind and
intention is a great starting point you
know it's a starting point for every
goal
having the intention of every dream that
you have
it is the creative power that fulfills
in our needs you know whether it happens
to be love or in relationships health
money or wealth right think about it
everything happens
in life began with an intention some
kind of intention when you decided to
buy that gift when you if you decide to
wiggle your fingers if you decide to
text a friend
if you want to remember someone's name
it all starts with the intention of
doing so
right uh wayne dyer says our intention
creates our reality think about that our
intention
creates our reality
right
i uh i know oprah has mentioned talk the
power of intention also as well that
intention is he says tension is one
with cause and effect and so intention
it determines our our outcome right and
she mentions in one of her quotes that
if you're stuck moving forward you have
to check the thought and the action that
has created your your circumstances so
that's the power of intention and so
how do we
learn how do we live
less out of habit and more through
intention
and let's just think about that when
you're focusing your mental energy on
something
that
let's say we're able to give more of our
brain power to it it's not
magic at all because there's a method
behind the magic you know it's our
innate
tool that we have this is the power of
the mind being placed in a position
where you are planning where you are
preparing where you need to be able to
perform at
optimal levels right
and so intention isn't a do it once and
and forget about it
it's not that kind of thing it's this
continuous consistent use of the mind in
a focused manner and when you cultivate
this state and use it you can get what
you want in life easier when we're
thinking about cultivating the state of
intention there are there are three
clear steps right so you could write
this down or you'll probably easily
remember this number one is you have to
decide what you want and that's in your
head right you have to decide what you
want uh this now
by the way when you're
by definition the power of intention you
need to know
what your goal is right when you're
thinking about intention
the aim
you know is
the goal
the dream so you set that intention
if you don't know this you're never
going to be able to utilize your power
because clarity gives you power
right the very easy phrase to remember
is i commit myself to this i
commit myself to
remembering people's names i commit
myself to a memory where i parked the
car that could be your intention most
people just par they're mindless right
they park their car or they go on
autopilot they're not thinking about
things or they're at home and you put
something somewhere but they're inten
there's no
intention behind
uh remembering where that thing is right
because they're not mindful and i'm
going to do a specific episode on
mindfulness so the first step is
get in your head right what do you want
and what do you want with clarity and so
what's your intention around learning
and your intention around life right the
second thing i would say is from head
you go into your heart
all right this this is really your your
why you have to get clear on your why
you know
now that you know what you want why why
do you want it
you know what is it going to give you
because reasons reap results reasons
reap results and honestly
reasons reap rewards also as well
because a lot of people know what to do
here in their head but they don't do it
with their hands which is the third part
because they're not connected with their
heart the emotions the energy of motion
right so you set the intention in your
head
right you feel it in your heart in terms
of why you must do it right simon sinek
has a great book called start with why
and then finally the third stage really
is your hands head hard hands and that's
where you work for it right once you
know what you want and why you want it
that serves as a great foundation it's
very attractive
you know but you can't have the law of
attraction without the law of action
right even you can see the word action
in the word attraction right so you
can't even make up you can't even make
the word attraction without the word
action literally the last six letters of
attraction is the word what action right
and so that gets to your hands and so
what is your intention in your head and
then feel the intention in your heart in
terms of why you want it and then be
very intentional
with your hands meaning the method
you're going to take place right because
your intention it's a it's a it's almost
a guiding principle of how you want to
be on how you want to learn on how you
want to live on how you want to show up
in the world activation energy is
something that was first introduced into
the field of human behavior in
psychology several decades ago by a rock
star professor at the university of
chicago that studied a state of flow his
name was mihai chiksen mihai and he
studied was one of the first really to
study human behavior human performance
and he coined this term activation
energy actually borrowed it from
chemistry and it's a term that describes
this phenomenon in order to start
any kind of chemical reaction it takes a
tremendous amount of energy to create
that initial spark a lot more energy to
start it than to keep it going
there's a direct correlation to you and
me
have you ever noticed how hard it is to
just get started how hard it is to get
to the gym how hard it is to get out of
bed how hard it is to put down
the bottle when you go to pour a second
drink and you know you shouldn't
that feeling how hard it is to get
started
this is what mihai's talking about
you need activation energy to start the
chain
to start to sit down to start to get out
of bed to start to walk out the door
that's the key to creating any kind of
change this activation energy inside of
you that causes the initial
boom
and then what do we hear over time once
you start there's a chain reaction and
that allows you to keep going
so what's this have to do with the
five-second rule freaking everything the
five-second rule
creates
activation energy in you the five-second
rule is how you activate change inside
of you it is a tool when you start
counting five four three two one
you awaken your prefrontal cortex you
begin the process of changing you push
yourself in a new direction that first
push
that's going to be the hardest once you
get moving it gets so much easier you
have access to a hundred percent of your
brain all of the time
but does that mean that we actually use
the whole brain all of the time and the
answer is no because what we start to
find out is when we start to live in
patterns and in habits that what happens
is we just activate certain neuronal
pathways that are habitual pathways and
as a result these are the pathways that
have preference in our everyday life
but if you can engage whole brain
activity you can enhance your
consciousness and your awareness and
your ability to control your life so
basically says that we can become whole
brain when we start to think
holistically instead of just playing
recurrent programs that play over and
over again and activate the same
pathways
so the relevance is that once we start
to engage in whole brain activity we
enhance our ability as humans on this
planet and now we're beginning to find
out there are many different ways to
engage and activate the whole brain
some of them involve simple exercises
such as something called brain gem and
brain gym is a very interesting exercise
of the body and the nervous system
integration in this way
my right hand is controlled by my left
hemisphere
my left hand is controlled by my right
hemisphere but here's an interesting
story if my right hand controlled by my
left hemisphere crosses the midline
then it simultaneously gets picked up by
the other hemisphere because now it's in
that territory as well so when you cross
your arms and when you cross your legs
what you're doing is causing the right
and the left hemispheres to work
together in harmony
when we are activating brain
synchronization where right and left
hemispheres are engaged together
simultaneously
it activates something like super
learning with both hemispheres working
together we have much more superior
characteristics of neural function
however after age seven and eight
we start to express what is called brain
dominance meaning during the day we
don't have synchronization of both
hemispheres during the day it's like a
wave form sometimes we're more in the
left hemisphere sometimes we're more in
the right then it comes back to the left
and back to the right so that we're
cycling through
one hemisphere at a time this is called
brain dominance where one hemisphere is
dominant over the other hemisphere well
the relevance about that is integrating
our lives is very difficult in brain
dominance for simple reason
has been suggested our left hemisphere
is based on logic and details
our right hemisphere is actually
associated with emotions and wholeness
and this becomes very important because
if you're only looking with your left
hemisphere then all the logic things
make sense but there's no emotional
component to it
and reverse if you're in the right
hemisphere you get emotionally tied up
but the logic drops out well this
happens to us ever since the time we
were eight through our adult life if you
can get both hemispheres to be in sync
hemisync
then you're engaging logic and emotions
at the same time that opens up a window
for super learning opportunities where
you can download information very very
quickly and very fast but it also opens
up a whole wide range of thinking that
includes an emotional component as well
as an intellectual component which is
necessary to fulfill a whole picture so
if you're operating from brain dominance
you're actually shutting off one
component of your nervous system at that
time
so if you do an exercise like brain gym
where you're involved with crossing your
arms and your legs
when you do that you start to integrate
both very interestingly when we have
hemisync we're much more calm collected
and able to really
express neurological functions that are
very fully supporting of ourselves
and this is why it's very interesting
when you go home and relax at night
sometimes you find yourself with your
ankles crossed over each other just
sitting in your chair without even
knowing what you're doing by crossing
your ankles you're actually engaging a
whole brain process so if you're
stressed for example during the day or
you just want to relax when you go home
at night crossing your arms and legs
actually engages both hemispheres which
calms the system down but engages a
whole brain process so you become much
more effective in your relaxed state so
if you're having a tough moment during
the day just take a moment and cross
your arms and legs hold them together
and just wait for about three or four
minutes and you'll start to feel a
calmness overcome
and in this calmness your neurological
functions will be totally enhanced when
we start to operate from patterns that
are replayed every day we start to
express very specific pathways that are
reused over and over and over again and
as a result we actually shut down a
large amount of functioning of the brain
and just go through the habit the
patterns that replay themselves over and
over again
so basically what you really have to
understand is this
we can use a hundred percent of the
brain but if we play the same patterns
over and over again we don't need to use
a hundred percent of the brain
so um simple point i'd just like to
suggest that once you start to recognize
that you can have hemisink where you can
get right and left hemispheres to engage
together and stay conscious you are
using 100 of your brain activity and
when you do that you'll also find that
your life is easier more harmonious and
healthier because when you're using your
full nervous system it will support your
life and enhance your growth
and this becomes important so don't get
stuck that i'm only using ten percent of
my brain that story is false
you can use a hundred percent
and it's available to us
and basically all you have to understand
is this stay conscious stay mindful and
stop playing the same patterns over and
over again because that opens up an
opportunity to create new behavior when
you stop playing the programs i realized
that god wasn't going to give me a get
out of jail free card
and from the time i was born
into the time i was 19 years old
my wife had these hurdles i constantly
hit obstacles
obstacle after obstacle after obstacle
and
i i had to figure out how to manage
suffering how how to deal with it
because it could be part of my life
forever at least that's what i thought
so in order to deal with it
i had to be able to conquer it and
overcome it and deal with it know that
in this suffering that has to be some
kind of growth
with every obstacle i look at as
friction now without friction there is
no growth
you have to have friction in your life
to grow
so i started looking at all these
different things versus the what was me
mentality like oh my god look at my life
my life's so [ __ ] up i come from this
family i'm being beaten i'm being abused
mentally physically
i start looking at it as a as the
perfect trial ground
try to flip it upside down it's okay i'm
suffering tremendously mentally
use this to your advantage versus your
disadvantage
so that's what i did versus looking at
it as like oh my god what was me i'm
never gonna get out of here i looked at
okay hang on a second
hang on a second if i can overcome this
if i can find some power in this some
way to get through this
that right there would be the fuel for
the rest of my life
and so i found great strength and
suffering
great strength in it because why through
all of that
it started to callous my mind
over the victim's mentality this whole
thing about suffering
yeah it sucks
really bad
uh really really bad
but we all live
on this side of suffering
on this side this nice box that's very
comfortable that we know when
everything's gonna happen we're in it
it's good we know how everything's going
to turn out
it's those few people who are willing to
go on the on this side of suffering
and once they get through that
ask him how he feels now
his mind
how far he grew
in that short period of time
he grew so much more than a normal
person because he was willing to go
outside himself because on the other end
of suffering
is greatness
it's not over here so a whole bunch of
us we put ourselves in this great box
and in that box there's no suffering in
it
so what we do is we if we
result to ourselves
from greatness
so for me for instance i was 300 damn
pounds
at one time in my life
spray for cockroaches made a thousand
dollars a month
i was living in that box
i would sometimes look over the box and
i saw hell suffering storms avalanches
tornadoes i don't want to go over there
but i knew if i could get through that
mentally
on the other side was 185 pound person
who's a navy seal went through ranger
school only person to do this only
person do that only person do this but
that's through all that
all that i have to go through so you
peek over the box and you go back in and
say oh i'm okay being 300 pounds making
a thousand dollars a month i'm okay over
here
and on the other side is where you start
to really start your journey
people think they start their journey
because they're born
no there's a lot of people in graves who
have lived 100 years
and have never started their real
journey
your real journey starts when you go
outside that box
and you start climbing mountains and
start climbing mountains and you think
you're top of the mountain you go down
the other side of you think i'm here you
look at [ __ ] there's another fountain
and it goes on and it goes on and it
goes on and just when you're getting
ready to quit
[Music]
you crest that final mountain you get
down and you look
and there you are
and it starts to make sense to you then
it doesn't make sense to you until you
get outside that box i'll talk to so
many people and what i say is not for
everybody
so many people don't have any clue
on what the i'm saying because they're
in this box
and it's their brain
you first must go through suffering to
find that great peace we're all looking
for a lot of us want to have there's a
lot of books out there
about this five steps
do this do this do this get there no man
it's not that easy to find real
permanent
peace and enlightenment
you must go to the dark side of who you
are
i could have easily just shoved my whole
life under a rug and went straight to
peace
are you happy there
you overcame nothing
you jumped hell
you skipped hell
for you you forgo
this part of your life you skip it and
go right to peace
so you always have this thing back here
that's haunting you and that's that
darkness
you must go into the darkness to truly
find that light that you're looking for
because that's what's on the other side
of that
people get it all wrong man
you have to face suffering
you have to face this dark side this
darkness and there's a lot of energy in
there
there's a lot of goodness in there
that you can use to find greatness
but you cannot find your peace you're
looking for in yourself
until you've overcome yourself a habit
is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind so now the
person
running through the same routine every
single day is on autopilot and their
body's now dragging them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is the sweet spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled
they start getting more afraid more
anxious more depressed and now the body
is literally being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all of the
body's resources for some threat whether
it's real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion
and in a sense they become addicted to
the life they don't even like
and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours then the body's
saying you're out of schedule you
normally at eight in the morning you're
getting traffic and you're angry then at
11 o'clock you check your emails and
you're really judgmental and frustrated
the body's saying well you've been doing
this for the last 20 years you're just
going to stop today so now the body
which has been conditioned emotionally
to be the mind wants to return back to
its familiar territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on this is a
good time to judge that come on this is
a good time to suffer it's your ex's
fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh er er you
know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so
that's when the person makes the same
choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling
okay i'll complain just so i can feel
suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy then step into the unknown to
step into possibility and the hardest
part about that process
first of all is not making the same
choice as you did day before
and here's the payoff
you got to stay conscious and not go
unconscious and it turns out that 95 of
the time we're unconscious so if you're
going to stay conscious then there's an
element that also requires a certain
amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so
the thoughts that they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and your tweeting and your
instagramming and facebook and whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm gonna feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then
if you say then you're not going to live
in the familiar future familiar past or
predictable future you're not going to
think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do you you
labor
uh for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment you're executing a will now
that's greater than the program and if
the person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from body as energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're
working and lowering the volume of that
emotion the more they lower the volume
of that emotion the more they're going
to take their attention off that person
and problem and they're going to take
their power back there's going to be a
break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else and when that occurs and
the person starts thinking differently
and they start acting differently
and they start feeling differently
they're a new personality and yeah they
they start seeing those synchronicities
and serendipities now
crossing that river of change
the creative process now gets exciting
because what thoughts do you want to
fire and wire in your brain what kind of
attention and intention
do you want to place so that that
becomes the loudest voice in your head
and if you keep practicing it the
hardware becomes a software program and
it'll say jay you can do anything jay
you live in no time and accomplish
everything jay
you're unlimited you just got to hang
with it on the other side of this is
greatness whatever you want to program
in there you get the program in there we
have five senses sight smell touch taste
and hearing now all of these have
different triggers so if we think about
food you see good food right or let's
say you see junk food you smell that
junk food you know what that junk food
tastes like you don't hear junk food i
don't think anyway and as soon as that
happens there's a response that goes
straight to your mind now what happens
in your mind and as you can see this is
a very accurate drawing of what your
mind really looks like inside but this
area of your mind it reminds you of your
past experiences you've had so when you
see those fries you smell those fries
you see those fries you touch those
fries it sends a response to your mind
your mind knows what those fries taste
like it remembers the last time you had
them and how good they felt and
straightaway goes yes let's have them
and so the mind goes sure let's go and
plan and create and now we have those
now we start to eat that and that is a
recurring habit and cycle in our life it
happens from everything from food that's
bad for us to toxic relationships
through to making bad career decisions
the simple act of reminding ourselves of
a positive experience with someone or
something allows us to continue that
repetition but now we all know this
we all know that discipline is a core
pillar in success
we all know that being able to resist
the urges of the mind can help us be
more focused
we all don't want to just be carried
away procrastinating and overthinking
all day we also don't want to live in a
place where we just keep feeding our
bodies and minds with stuff that's not
good for it i know that you feel that i
know that's why you're here and so
there's one key thing that makes a
difference now give me a moment while i
draw this for you it's pretty much a
work of art so i need some privacy just
to get this right
so now as you can see the god is the
monk mind
the intelligence the monk mind that
stands in between the senses and the
mind so now
for most of us our monk mind is asleep
our god is absolutely asleep or has been
lazy for a while and therefore we've
been in this recurring pattern but this
now creates a new conversation so now
every time there's something that you
see that you want or smell or touch or
taste or hear
it first goes to the god
and the god may say well by the way you
just made a commitment last week that
you want to stay off eating sugar you
just made a commitment last week that
you were going to work out three days a
week right i'm gonna make sure that you
stick to that so even though your eyes
are saying that bed looks more comfy
than that bench press we are gonna go
back and now it stops you from having
that direct conversation with your mind
which is always looking for that monkey
mind and the easy way out so you've now
added a level of conversation that's
stronger but you're like but jay i mean
you know is that willpower is that
internal strength where does that god
where does that monk mind come from so
the monk mind comes from the following
principle so the way we strengthen the
monk mind and the god inside our minds
so that we don't just give in to the
temptations and the urges of the mind is
through the four r's format so these
four r's have to be done in order and
when they're executed effectively you
will know that your guard and your monk
mind is getting stronger the first r is
reason
you need a really powerful reason for
why you're making this new change in
your life if you don't have a deep
profound reason in your life it'll be
really really difficult i'll give you an
example if someone says that they want
to quit drinking alcohol just because
they want to do it it's different from
someone saying i want to quit drinking
alcohol because i want to save my family
i want to keep my family together and
this habit is ruining our interactions
and so i really want to kick this habit
notice the difference in reason right
even if we want to learn something it's
like oh i want to learn to play an
instrument why oh just because i feel
like it or i want to learn to play an
instrument because i want to propose by
playing the piano notice the depth of
reason reason is the first r that's
needed to strengthen the god and it's
almost like the god building its
foundation so the monk mind is based on
creating a strong sense of reason now
what i want you to do is choose that one
thing you're trying to change in your
life right now
and i want you to ask yourself what's
your real reason for wanting to change
it what is your deep reason for wanting
to change it now our reasons can also be
negative or positive
a negative reason can be revenge or
negative reason can be getting our own
back or showing people right it's kind
of like that look at me now kind of
feeling and we know that in the long
term that won't satisfy us because again
we're seeking validation from someone
feeling differently about us but our
reason being for people that we love
a reason being for ourselves a reason
being a really
heartfelt
deep internal belief that if we don't
change this
it's not going to be good for us all the
people we love and so the first r is
having a really strong reason so i'm
just going to write that down
so reason putting a check next to reason
the second r that we need in our life
is research your reason is given more
ammunition and depth through good
research what i mean by that is you may
pick up the phone to a coach you may
speak to someone who's already mastered
that habit you may focus on reading
about books and watching documentaries
and listening to podcasts about that
subject the more you absorb information
the more likely you are to create
transformation remember that the more
you absorb information the more you're
likely to create transformation because
now you have so much research that is
consistently convincing the god to help
convince the senses every time you want
something or see something or chase
something the god can say but do you
remember when we read that study
do you remember when we watched that
documentary do you remember when you
spoke to that coach and all of a sudden
you have so much more reasoning power
when you research so the second step is
research and the best way are books
podcasts and people
right books podcasts and people are the
best forms of research when you want to
create a habit change in your life make
sure that what you listen to what you
read and what you speak about is about
the subject you're trying to grow in
when you immerse yourself in that way
you will see maximum impact in your life
so the second r is research
the third r
is repetition
repetition
if we don't consistently make this a
priority in our life it's just not going
to happen we have to repeat that action
so we have to prioritize around it and
this is something i say often right if
you really want to make something a
priority in your life
it has to be a small step and a big
priority often what we try and do is we
try and change every area of our life
and then naturally nothing changes but
the better thing to do is choose one
area and make it your top priority so if
you want to start going to the gym make
that the one big thing you're going to
achieve that day and set a time that you
can actually make it don't set it at an
awkward time i know someone who
literally used to struggle working out
so instead of that what she would do is
when she would roll off the bed she
would have her yoga mat and all of her
gym equipment laid out right near her
bed so she had no excuse right it was
the first thing she saw in the morning
and so she could naturally start
exercising straight away that also is
true for not triggering the senses right
repetition also includes if you're
trying to stay off sugar if you just
don't have any sugar items in your
closet or in your cupboard or in the
fridge then there's no chance that
you're going to have it so you can
actually save yourself by removing it
from the trigger of the senses
so that is repetition
the fourth r is responsibility right you
want to be able to do this with someone
you want to feel like you're growing
with someone that's why having a tribe
or a community or a group of people that
are trying to aim for the same thing
means you're more likely to get there
you know if you're trying to start a new
habit like cycling more if you're
cycling with a group of people now guess
what you're not just relying on your
motivation you're relying on 10 other
people to motivate you as well if you're
going to the gym with a friend
responsibility and accountability makes
you more likely to get to your
destination and there's a fifth hour
actually that i just thought of and it's
called reward you want to make sure that
in any habit change there is some reward
and a reward is making sure you
recognize what amazing growth you're
making that you're taking a moment to
see look how far i've come because our
mind again tricks us and always goes
look how far you have to go it's really
important that you remind yourself of
how far you've come how much you've
grown the difference you've made so the
fifth and final r is reward get your
goals straight and continue to practice
every day and if you're not succeeding
then make your goals slightly smaller
you want to you want to make your goals
large enough so that they challenge you
but small enough so that you have a
reasonable probability of succeeding at
them on a day-to-day basis
and then you have to also understand
that if you fail on a given day like
let's say you're trying to quit smoking
and you quit for two weeks and then you
have a cigarette and you think oh my god
now i've screwed it up i've i'm not
quitting anymore you smoke a whole pack
of cigarettes it's like well
there's a couple of mistakes there and
one is
well just because you had a cigarette
doesn't mean you failed it just means
that you had a cigarette you can start
stopping again the next day
and the fact that you had one cigarette
in the last two weeks is a hell of a lot
better than the two weeks that you had
before that
and so you've got to be
realistically humble you've got to be
ambitious enough in your goals so that
you're pursuing something that you
regard as truly meaningful and
worthwhile
you know and maybe you can judge that to
some degree if you think about someone
you love attempting the same thing and
think about how you would feel if they
managed it and if you would feel good
then that's probably a good
what would you say that would be a good
evaluation strategy to use on yourself
create an affirmation that you repeat
over and over to yourself
this repetition dramatically increases
the speed at which you develop the new
habit for example you can say something
like
i get up and get going immediately at
six a.m each morning repeat these words
the last thing before you fall asleep
in most cases you will automatically
wake up minutes before the alarm clock
goes off at 6 00 am and soon you will
need no alarm clock at all
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn to take control of your
mind with deepak chopra check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there he's a magical lie
how do we live a life with zero physical
or mental weakness it's loneliness comes
from the fear
of the ego